good old surf shock back again they are
sponsoring today's true news which means
you can get a virtual private network
anywhere it does a lot of things first
of all the thing that everyone always
goes on about in all their ads is hey
you can access content in other
countries if you do want to go to
another country watch some other
countries content i know america's
probably one of your favorites you might
be french living in england sort of like
wisdom of french content or maybe you're
italian influencers in japan
well now you can watch itv bbc all these
ones they won't know because you've got
a vpn in the uk a virtual private
network one good thing it does oh yeah
if you're in a country with a censorship
with that yeah you can get around it
right how do you mean always then you
can get around it see the websites you
want because the government can't go
oh we're telling you what it looks like
or if you're in look at what i want if
you're in like
north korea i guess shouldn't be good if
you're i don't know if surf shark's
available in north korea i'm just saying
how many people are watching this video
specifically in north korea
in the comments then yes sort of
north korean loyal that way you won't
get in trouble your own people either
you know because if he sees that he'll
go probably loyal to me you can also
just stay safe on public wi-fi public
wi-fi is actually quite dangerous i
don't know if you've heard of this
before brian really
yeah you know when you go into a station
or a starbucks or a cafe or something
people can
get in there take some of your personal
details not if you've got this virtual
private network no one can touch you
protects you
can't touch this
[Music]
shock okay close and surf shark also
offers one account that you can use
across
unlimited devices and if you guys want
it now then there's actually an
incredible offer to get you signed up
and i know what you're thinking tell me
the offer
i'll tell you the offer you'll probably
want to hear it from me first yeah
probably because
it's got your name in it it's got your
name in it i'm sorry the guy
that they have all come to see on i
suppose they're all wondering then what
would that offer be brian how can i hear
that offer well i'll get the bit longer
you could audibly express it just now 83
off with
three months extra freelancer oh of
course you also need to use code geordi
at checkout and that'll get you this
amazing offer but now
it's time for some true news
uh welcome back the true news it's the
news that's true and if you thought
jake paul was annoying before he's about
to knock [__] out of an mma champion
all right do you know what's mental his
hair let's we'll just say it his hair is
mental not jake paul
he used to put a lot of effort into his
videos i think his face whether you like
him or not
the videos were pretty [__] mental
yeah right
now it's just him in a nightclub with
his mother sup [__]
[__] no he's just in a call just like
yeah i'm just gonna
he realized you don't need he doesn't
give a [__] the effort in you don't need
to put the effort in here
man this this guy is scared of me he's
saying oh we can't fight
because of kobe we can't fight because
of kobe actually now is the best time to
fight
go train in a gym since you can't you
can't do anything else you can't go out
to eat you can't do
go to the movie train not now is the
best time to train ksi
jj doesn't fight when jake tells him he
fights when they agree and they haven't
agreed
the one thing i will say i know for a
fact that jj is not scared
of jake paul oh he told you i just fully
believe it he's just game as [__] though
you've seen the way he fights like
he's not scared he fought the bigger
brother and he
ran after him the whole fight pretty
much i think jj just wants to be do it
in his own good time sure exactly yeah
and obviously jake wants her i do credit
jake though the guy is game and he's
trying to have as many fights as
possible and that is going to put him in
the best position
when they do fight i really don't know
what ksi is doing i doubt that fight's
ever going to happen i'm just going to
be
fighting these mma these professional
fighters and my skill level just growing
and growing and growing i'm not gonna go
back i'm gonna go backwards and fight a
youtuber who i'm just gonna kill
i disagree i get the logic from jake in
terms of the higher competition he's
fighting right now
is gonna make him better that is a fact
but if the opportunity comes up to fight
ksi you will absolutely take that yeah
he's wanted this fight for years now
jake clearly wants to fight immediately
that that is
clear as dave if ksi doesn't fight all
year and you've had three fights this
year alone two fights last year whether
the [__] it works out you're going to be
in a great
place to have that fight so i feel like
you should just take as many fights as
you can and see it as an advantage
but you guys saw yesterday is official
april 17 jake paul versus ben askren
this is how far this has gone
jake paul is going to fight a guy who
was an mma champion
that is insane people have been able to
discredit denchy
kibble joe weller uh now nate robinson
they're not real fighters they're not
real fighters
this is a man who was an olympic level
wrestler an
athlete yeah we're not just talking
about someone who's never been in a
physical confrontation and then did a
few months of boxing we're talking about
a man who i think was over 20 mma fights
where he won
titles in organizations whether he's a
good stand-up fighter or not i know
it's not his strength obviously
wrestling was this thing you cannot take
that away from this cannot be
discredited right or you you only
thought what an mma champion you can't
go out with you only fought
a basketball you can't do that this time
love him i hate him
jake paul deserves credit for this both
these guys are doing
really something for the community of
funny looking guys with fluffy hair
triller's putting on the show there's
gonna be musical performances crazy
under cards we're talking to different
influencers different boxers yeah yeah
yeah you messaged me um what did he say
do you want to join me on the undercode
sort of thing
wow jake paul which one
gearbox you already done him up so
that's one one under your belt
definitely not is the answer yeah i i've
been ill for about a month i haven't
been in a gym for six weeks the main
point i don't want to be a boxer right i
just want to learn how to box so that i
could be better at
talking about i think i'm currently
doing four live streams a week there's
no way i can um
be like oh say bye to all the stuff and
i'm just gonna be a boxer now yeah
thanks for the offer jake but um this is
a hobby for me
yeah and uh respect for what you're
doing i said you know what i mean yeah
absolutely
yeah respect what you're doing
essentially what you should have also
kept as a hobby
i mean the guy's making [__] millions
now any so if i was going to get jake
paul logan paul money
[__] everyone [__] the kickoff right
[__]
everyone here geo the lot of them this
all started
you know back with gibb when people were
like oh gibb is the best gibb is the
best
bit disrespectful to deji just
completely wiping away all
a whole chapter of the boxing yeah this
all started with kim
okay all right no nothing relevant there
before
happened i must say yeah it's not like
you went six rounds with deji and deji
pushed you teddy's been
i don't know he tweets out every now and
then like oh i want that rematch and
i'm like just to be fair to gabe the
jake paul that gib fault
and the jake paul that deji for or two
different people all together absolutely
jake has levelled up so much in two
three years we've just not seen deji how
do you know
well i mean that's the point isn't it
that's where ben asking comes in
he's 19-2 has less losses than mcgregor
he's a bellator mma champion two-time
division one
ncaa he played fifa as well great that's
brilliant he made it to division one as
well so he has got staying
power in america that means he's elite
level wrestlers right is he as good as
stone cold steve austin they were
talking to a couple different guys to
make the fight happen dylan dan has
blamed his knee injury
some other people had different other
excuses at the end of the day ben askren
had the balls to get in the ring with me
so
we're making it happen do you know
what's a good thing about jake he's an
agitator
right he doesn't care who he upsets so
even though dylan danis
legitimately probably has a knee injury
jake doesn't go i respect that he's a
knee injury he goes [__] now because he
had a knee injury he just turned up and
pelted him with water balloons yeah
toilet roll yeah speaking of agitating
he's been dming ben askren's wife
already
the problem is when the wife replies she
why
don't you you're laying next play it
play this out with me you're ben askren
i'll be the wife
what what's uh nothing just a state
wrestler
rest messaging me sorry do you know this
guy
uh is it jack paul jack powell i'm jake
paul i'm fighting him yeah
what yeah i'm fighting him you didn't
tell me yeah we're gonna have a boxing
match
what's he what are you sending me is a
picture of his dick
uh love you love you kiss kiss kiss
beautiful
he's got a massive [__] by the way
absolutely [__] huge
now let us say hello to the man who will
be fighting
ben askren is that love hearts on jake's
hand it sure is
imagine getting knocked out by a man
with love hearts tattooed on his hand
that would
flowers it adds insult to injury though
yeah like a pretty little design
pretty yeah that's pretty it's a rose
yeah you do plenty of damage with your
little pretty hands
i think people don't like to give me
props for my boxing ability but
deep down they're like damn this kid
this kid can can fight we were talking
about five or six guys
and mma fighters some celebrities
uh an nfl guy and when it came down to
the ink
meeting the paper and then being like
green lighting this and being like let's
do this
it turned out a lot of them weren't as
serious as we thought
i agree i think there's probably a few
mma fighters out there who
were all about it they get the contract
in front of them and they start thinking
what if i lose to the [__] youtube
kid you become the meme of memes
and jake is the biggest meme distributor
of them all the guy is
he's going to ruin your life a bit you
would struggle to look dana white in the
eye if you did lose
you sort of go back and go i told you
this [__] i told you don't go fight
those [__] youtubers yeah
and they go i'm sorry i'm sorry dana and
he goes no you can't [__] come back
go to bellator you've got dylan dennis
for example
jake paul offered this guy 500 000 to
fight him and the fight didn't happen
now i
the guys obviously got a knee injury it
does make you wonder or people just
going i don't want to be that guy
you have a mcgregor moment and you go
i'll easily win this you get in there
catches you [__] you're [__] down and
you look like an eight-year-old man on
the floor when you're on the floor it's
not good he told me earlier today
he predicts a seventh round tko of you
what's your response to that ben ice
cream literally went yeah i don't have a
lot of power so it's probably gonna take
us a while yeah that was mental
i was watching like ben you're not
you're not helping maybe ben's just
realistic whereas you know jake's the
[__]
he is so honest and he's just very
matter of fact yeah they
they sent me a contract over so i just
thought well got nothing else to do and
i need to get in shape
so probably should just do it but that's
what they were hoping you would do
yeah i mean this is the thing though i
don't have to take brain damage
to make money locally so you already got
enough of that my response is go google
ben asking striking
is it just me or the more you watch jake
paul the more you like him this is the
thing though i think a lot of people
hate him but when you understand that
he's just
embraced the villain i appreciate it
like i i i
you know he's the [__] but he knows
what he's doing imagine the amount of
[__] this guy must get i mean i get a
lot of grief on social i can't imagine
mike tyson did an interview and he was
like yeah there's something wrong with
this guy
i'm like yeah i think he might be right
like when mike tyson says
there's something wrong with you that's
like that is a diagnosis he's completely
unaffected
by all of this [__] and also under the
lights he really performs well he's
clearly studied the mcgregor player book
of how to get in people's heads
wind people up draw them into a fight i
noticed on your instagram
that you only follow two people now
triller and
ben's wife why is that she
thick bro if you're ben's wife why
aren't you just blocking him he messaged
her like hey baby
she messaged back she goes i say you're
selling your property in la uh if you
need a realtor
let me know wow and like she just served
him up like
so calmly i think there's an angle
building here like he'll do this for the
fighting community do you feel like this
is
jake paul versus mma says jake paul
versus the
like just to be clear every single mma
fan
is right now chanting into some sort of
ben askren doll
hoping that to give him their energy
like you have a ben asking dog
they all are praying that he knocks [__]
out of jake paul
jake paul has got that same energy that
others have used in the past where he
preys on the fact that everyone's
rooting against him floyd mayweather was
the
the best at this right everyone wanted
him to get knocked clean out and
he would make you think it could happen
right and then it wouldn't happen
i do wonder if jake's on a track where
because he said so much [__]
it's kind of dodgy to put that karma out
there like you could argue
conor mcgregor recently kind of got what
was coming to him for years and years
when you put that out there it can
backfire
but nothing ventured nothing gained
brian and this man is venturing a lot
and this man is gaining a lot
you know what damn i respect that oh
it's really hard this episode isn't it
there's not really a lot me to be honest
with you there's loads i mean we've got
the bell delphian rape scandal
i suppose we can talk about it because
we're like the only podcast who have not
had her on so we can be
objective on it we can stand back and go
look we've not seen that
in real life what is the whole yeah here
yeah not that pose
no although that is part of the problem
um she basically used to be like an
internet personality girl who would do
only funds and then now
lately she's just gone full porno with
her boyfriend or as we say she chose to
call a spade a spade
she had her boyfriend dress up really
weirdly he's dressed up as like a teddy
bear do they play the teddy bears picnic
or
dick pic if you go down to the woods
today you're in for a big surprise
your girlfriend's getting poked by oh
this is a different one i'm just showing
laurence
bell delphine's video with her boyfriend
you can see he's sort of pushing in um a
dildo that looks like a baguette
this is our boyfriend dressed up as a
[__] bear right we've all done it it
really does look like a baguette doesn't
it yeah
i don't know why but i feel like i want
to go for a subway they pull that uh
footlong they pull the the rest of his
outfit off but they leave the teddy bear
head on so he gets anonymity
that way whenever when anyone sees him
walking down the street holding his
girlfriend's hand they'll have no idea
who he is
so she dabbled in porn right and then
came her idea to
be sort of consensually taped taken
right okay you know held down in the
woods and stuff
i don't know where we'd find the images
well i'm certainly not googling them on
my laptop
no but so this is a picture which we can
show
oh the poor girl it's basically her
being kidnapped and
a lot of people obviously were triggered
by this because
why you know people who've been through
horrible experiences like this will see
this appearing on their twitter feed and
be like you're sort of
trivializing a very serious subject i'll
read out some of these accusations
beldelphine dressing as a child
pretending to get kidnapped and
i'll just say raped and people simp over
her you need
a psychological evaluation quite frankly
if you support beldelphine you need to
get help
and be placed on a government watchlist
her response
was quite a detailed one she actually
gave a full so she'll go to bel delphine
twitter
twitter delphine all my clothes i wear
were made for adults so the thing
that people can comment on is maybe the
fact that i'm wearing a dress it's
confusing for me
oh i see she went down the deliberately
misinterpreting what people are saying
root okay so you know when you wear
things that are sized for adults but
they
look like child clothes that would still
mean they're in the theme of child
clothes
so you're not doing right there belle
alright you've not quite nailed it
when things are baby pink and baby blue
there's a reason we're
babies before them do you know what i
mean because they're made for young
little things not things like you when
you're being raped
it annoys me when people deliberately
get things wrong
and go so are you saying that these
clothes were made for children
no we're saying you look like a child
when you dress up in your stupid wigs
with your funny eyes
so she goes on and says i consented to
being tied up and having rough sex yes
that's fine i am not apologizing for
anything what i
did wasn't wrong and much more normal
than people think one of the most common
sexual outfits and fantasies
schoolgirl if you wear that are you
promoting pedophilia no because you're
doing it privately in the comfort of
your own home you're not posting the
[__] video online are you bell when
you do something in private that other
people can't see that you can't monetize
and you're not selling to
a band of pedophiles then i can do
whatever the [__] i want behind closed
doors but you're not behind closed doors
are you well technically you are doors
closed when you doing the filming
however you're filming you're taking the
card out and you're putting it beyond
the closed doors
do i have to explain privacy to you the
front page of porn websites include
fantasy scenarios of every different
kind you can think of
incest stepmom teacher now she's getting
to the right point okay
so earlier on she says i didn't do
anything wrong but then what she's doing
is she's comparing to social taboos it
seems that belle does understand
that is deliberately misinterpreting and
not typing things properly
just because someone likes the fantasy
of something doesn't mean
they want it in real life very good
point that's a good point good point
well made she saved us
a little bit yeah you did save yourself
a little bit there belle but i've still
got to admit if you're fantasizing over
[__] a child or a likeness of a child
let's be clear here it is a little bit
unusual say that i said to you brian you
know
last night i got my partner to dress up
as a dog and then we had sex
you wouldn't go you love [__] her as
a woman i go no i dress her up as a dog
because that was what i was thinking of
you worry that i wanted to [__] a dog in
real life you're really confusing me now
right yeah she did dress her boyfriend
as a bear
yes to be clear yes now that was
obviously that's very different because
bears are not sort of immediately in
danger of paedophilia or beast or
feeling i must admit if there's one
thing i'd feel confident in is that no
one's out there [__] bears right they
will claw your dick clean off
absolutely although it doesn't seem that
you're afraid with a phrase from the gay
community oh yeah that's right
there are a lot of people out there
[__] do you think i would know
looking like this with the leather
here's that when he's walking around in
london hasn't he yeah especially when
you put the mask thing on that you love
you know the one with the zip it's the
ball
yeah sex is complex and explorative good
point belle but
should always be consensual another good
point i post a lot of sexual stuff on my
twitter you do here's where we're
getting a little bit gray here belle
because it's for my only fans
no you said here belt now be absolutely
clear post on my twitter
that's a different platform to only fans
one platform
public for everyone to go and talk on
the other one
where people go for wanky wanks i think
some people
who aren't aware of the kind of pawns
that are out there may have come across
that because she posted it on twitter
i've been a bit shocked the reality is
she is a grown woman all right
dressing the way she dresses it's not my
thing but you know she should have the
right to do whatever the [__] she wants
whose thing do you think it is to watch
a grown woman
dress as a child whose thing is that can
i just say
i think maybe if she's gonna do that
kind of content that mimics
non-consensual or other forms of sex
that some people
might find traumatic maybe bring back
some memories
keep those ones off of twitter right you
know ultimately she can do whatever the
[__] she wants but maybe if she wants to
avoid this happening future
just watch what you're posting on social
media and then she'll keep the only
funds
for the the only fans i wasn't in mns
the other day
by you know just checking out having a
little chat with them behind the bar and
i went yeah and i had some rape sex last
night sorry what was the oh yeah
i was just mentioning it because i'm in
public and i just like rape sex what was
the oh
you're upset by that are you well that's
not my fault that's not that's not my
fault at all i should be able to say
rape sex to you and
i should be able to do whatever i want
in public oh oh i can't say it in front
of you now can't i
i should be able to say rape sex and
i'll say rape sex to everyone in marx
and spencer all right could you just you
do have neighbors
yeah we've got news rape sex okay we
have news
you should all have to listen to that
and scroll past it we do have nearby
oh sorry if that's triggering some of
you who've had some sexual abuse in your
lives
oh oh i'm the bad guy now am i let me
just check out my stuff
and i'll be leaving with my rape sex all
right
oh you make me sick i'm the victim here
in other news
zoella popular youtuber obviously the
queen of youtube in england for many
years
not anymore she's been up to no good
yeah what what's
been peddling smut keemstar says uh
zoella
has been criticized for years for trying
to sell multiple different things to her
fans the biggest hate she ever got was
for selling a calendar
today she's getting criticism for
selling sex toys many are saying her fan
base is underage girls
yeah i did see a bit about things that
took the she used to make wholesome
content for the children now she wants
you to probably
buy stuff off of our website and shove
it up your toys
i think she's of an age now where she
her careers you can't expect her to be
boxed in
and be the same young woman that she
wants but she's a grown woman now you
know and she's bound to be
flooding herself city and bloody loving
it with a stud muffin like i'll feeds
he'll be all over that so having said
that they've been together a long time
as well so you think this
got to keep it spiced up you know what i
mean having said that i'm just literally
imagining alfie
cracking a huge baguette in her having
said that
should zoella have maybe preempted this
pre-launch and gone
i do have some young fans and in the
next couple of weeks i will be talking
about sex
this isn't aimed at them if you do see
that don't click it is that an idea
maybe should we look at the dildos
she's peddling i don't know if we can
show this why not
i mean it's not a penis and it's not a
phallus i mean technically
it's definitely sorry i'm wrong there
that's a phallus you do shove it up a
hole yeah
you could shove it in any hole for
instance we should be able to show this
on youtube it's ridiculous
yeah i can't see why we wouldn't rub and
rub it g-spot stroking vibrato right now
the main problem here is right well
there's no problem with it lawrence it
looks a cracking better kit
yeah have you ever used one of these uh
i haven't actually right okay oh i'll
tell you what women love those ones
please what the hell do they
ever it's well there's a reason why they
love them brian it's called the dream
wand
rechargeable meaning it's a small one i
don't remember hermione having that one
no tell you am i right brian's got his
own rage the womanizer duo
i mean it's to be fair as both of us
clitorassy lesson number one
four and five clitoris owners reach
orgasm
via clitoral stimulation never have i
seen that
[Music]
no i do love the idea you know if you
fancy zoeler back in the day
now you can read this and think oh she's
been writing she's been writing all of
them very few people
should do their own research oh i'm
taking these home for a bit of market
research
yeah i don't think she'd ever announce
it to the office they'd always just go
where did that case of dildos that go
and they go
zoella and she'd just be she's in the
toilet she's in the trees
oh good god women are such complex uh
creatures aren't they
absolutely like with all the respect
girls even you must look at some of this
[__] and be like what the [__] am i
buying
like with men we are so straightforward
you guys you've got what we could
probably get some mittens do you know
what i mean little wanking
there's the the obvious one isn't there
there's just a thing that you just flesh
like
smash like you splunk that's disgusting
wash it afterwards absolutely this looks
like some sort of seychelles you found
at the beach with your grandma yeah
you can imagine you imagine your grandma
walks in and goes oh this is vibrating i
hear it's from the seaside
oh you can hear all of the waves
mr lover lover hello girls
they call me mr manscape dick is that
the uh
lawnmower 3.0 what this what that one
what this over here this is the lawn
mower 3.0 yeah and with valentine's day
coming around there's going to be a lot
of you thinking
that's such a good idea by the way this
is the hint that you've all been
wondering about right okay
you're sitting there going how can i
tell my man that he's a [__] hairy
piece of [__]
right there you go and then let me
valentine's day your hairy bastard trim
the balls
trim the arse and say you can also not
trim the balls but you want to trim his
nose hair life changer called the weed
whacker okay it's called the weed
whacker generally
get that up your nose give it a little
circle your motion up there and you are
good to go now i'll remind you these are
two very different things
nose balls and gooch you want to do in
the shower sure you can do that they're
waterproof
up to 90 minutes that'll last you so one
charge i don't know how many you could
literally do everyone in your household
yeah including your grandma yeah we've
all seen them and not only that but if
you wanted to do that so once the hairs
are in there so
caught in there you just unscrew it like
that just give it a little but then you
just sort of go
grand you're ready and straight you're
straight in straight up there
bang that's the nose not the you can get
20 percent off with our link launcher
exactly for valentine's day and if you
want to get that the link's in the
description but i'll also tell you what
the link is it's manscape.com forward
slash
true 20 off pretty sure you're welcome
yeah see you one of my favorite ufc
fighters
was out i think he was just getting some
petrol actually as well
and he was stopped by a police officer
where's your mask he didn't have one
he's actually exempt
um he's got a the whole thing about why
he's exempt yadda yadda not important
right now the point is
the copper just wouldn't let it go right
he didn't realize he was talking about a
ufc fighter either i don't think
yeah clearly the other cop i did though
so darren then went live on instagram
and thousands and thousands of people
watching this exchange
interesting that you're going to get
issues with a fine
do you know me with nothing like do what
you want
to call whatever you're a bully you're a
bully boy you're the bully boy
get out my car i'll [__] off just be
absolutely clear this is a very normal
interaction in liverpool
you can say that because you've got
family because i'm just very clear
that wasn't a dig it's a joke [__]
relax check
what you want check it all check it all
check it all i don't know if you can see
here the police officer in question
isn't actually wearing his mask
correctly at all look at him you're a
loser never have a problem with police
right
never you see you you're a bully boy
loser
literally look at the state of that man
he's actually having a good anyone for
not wearing a master [__] idiot
you are a bully boy loser this is what
you do you go to gyms
you bully everyone you bully boy may go
away i think darren is reflecting
a mood at the moment that people feel a
bit like oppressed by people and the way
that it's being enforced is not very
uh it's it's getting ridiculous i think
they got into that job obviously to try
and stop the bad guys but somewhere
along the way
taking it upon themselves to just think
that they can go up to anyone and do
anything at this point it's getting
crazy well it is easier to stop someone
who's not wearing a mask than a drug
dealer possibly i'd say it's much easier
to find them as well all right
you've got me details are you gonna
arrest me so send the flower whenever
you want
he's practically in his [__] car
though that's the thing like that would
freak you out a bit like your opinion
this is all that obviously darren till's
getting [__]
vexed right now but the point is this is
over him not wearing a mask when
just to be clear no one was around him
he's exempt like the cop has actually
come in to invade his personal space
not wearing his mask properly like if
we're like to believe that this is all
about public health and safety
this copper is actually doing the worst
thing you could be doing right yeah it's
really weird isn't
do what you it i've already told you i'm
gonna do it get off my door right now
i need to get off my to go that way the
fact that they're checking
tires and all this [__] now you never
know you can never be too safe
and that's what definitely he is
desperate to get him on anything and
that's what we're talking about here is
they're seeing police work
remember when police work was [__]
like catching bad guys and drug dealers
and all this all
now it's like masks too low like there's
a clip i've seen recently where they
come into a house
in scotland they've heard reports of
people having people over no
a daughter came home from hospital that
day that was the only thing and next
thing you know
the coppers are like pinning people down
all because
they were like yeah there's nothing
going on here what's the problem leave
it again
in my house
when did you guys lose what you became
like there's so many good police
officers out there they're not all like
this but some of them have just lost
their [__] way like and this coved
[__] it's giving them like license to
act how they want because so many of our
freedoms have been removed from the star
we're just sitting there like
all right you can't do anything without
someone feeling they've got the right to
arrest you now oh you're outside
to be totally honest with you this is
more for the kids
like i know i've always been very i
swear a lot on like
interviews and fights and apple i lost
my temper with that officer because
he was searching and fishing for
something like he followed me to my car
he wouldn't
let me get in my car he he just
obstructed me obstructing my night
wanting to do
anything and everything like so what you
can see there is dan till's actually
just a very reasonable nice guy
most the time i know he's made a few
mistakes yeah i mean he's an mma fighter
so there's obviously an
edge to the guy but like i i felt like
even though he went
off it and he probably wishes he didn't
that's the level that it's getting to
around the world at the moment sometimes
where people just feel like there's no
line anymore there's no respect like
[__] crazy you can't do anything
without someone stopping you and going
why are you doing that mate
something that was confirmed we you know
i've got to admit i didn't really know
who this person was
i've heard about before she's [__]
like a big youtuber or whatever
really 12 million subs she's basically a
children's entertainer hey everyone it's
jojo welcome back to my youtube channel
you guys
i am so excited i will not be showing my
son this
i do not want my kids to act like this
it just reminds me of like ironically
back in the day
this was kind of what jake paul and then
were like what's going on everybody
[Applause]
like when they're trying to get
attention for the kids and that they
feel like they've just got to scream at
them non-stop and it works i guess so
maybe they're right
yeah i understand that although my son
will just stop doing anything as long as
you go
the wheels on me will go what was that
so you guys
it's been so long since i've actually
gotten to babysit someone and i
love babysitting so much you're not old
enough to babysit someone you are 17 but
you look about eight
if this person turned up to babysit my
child again i go
you nope she does dress very
flamboyantly
it's nothing to do with the dressing
it's to the fact that she is so jazzed
i'm like it's the boys
you my love are a little bit too jazzed
to be sort of babysitting a child
admit i would i would be like we're
going to drug test you those are not a
numbers
no just putting that right now that kind
of energy we're not talking about a
numbers here we're talking about
ease test your piss you know today i am
babysitting
the one the only sienna
i'd be concerned at the level of
enthusiasm for babysitting what you got
in mind here that's exactly what i'm
saying why are you coming into my home
and more excited than i've ever been to
be in my own house
get out guys i'm so happy to be
babysitting your child she's not really
just swinging and going
well this is fun yeah the kid's looking
at you guys what the
[__] of you feels like he's on a wall
yeah exactly well not only that he's
he's probably tripping out he thinks
travis scott's coming to babysit him so
nick is my friend he called me and he
was like hey jojo i'm going on a date
tonight with my girlfriend zara can you
babysit sienna for me and i was like
100 of course i would love to how weird
is this
right that the video premise is a fellow
influencer dad
that this 17 year old girl knows is
giving his child to her
so that he can go out on a date this is
content now
this is all fake made up obviously but
this is like
people are watching this going oh my oh
she's babysitting no no she's not
babysitting at all
it's just [__] weird it's not wrong
it just sort of feels
off it feels off the fact that this
dad's going i know
i'll give my young daughter it was 17
year old influencer to babysit for a
video idea he's the weirdo he's
out of this whole scenario this guy's
the weird one right i'm not saying
something and this is a woman she's
dressed like that
right and she's seventeen in front of a
[__] unicorn behind her right when i
was 17
there were no unicorns around me
certainly not just to be clear
yeah although you did go to newcastle
there were on your badge so
that's a seahorse same thing to me the
fact that this girl
came out and anyone was surprised is the
surprise the girl's been giving us clues
for years look at that she's promoting
the rainbow
in a way that is this is her house by
the way this isn't a set design you're
not actually she lives there
and this is what she's surrounded by
she's been dropping clues for the
longest time right
so what you're saying is because the way
she decorates her house you think she's
a lesbian brian i'm just saying she's
been
we're gonna make tick tocks we're gonna
do homework we're gonna play with dolls
she's probably gonna want to play roblox
i know she loves roblox we're gonna
dance
she's gonna teach me how to sing she's
gonna play the piano this child might
die from exhaustion this girl's putting
energy into this video more energy than
i think we've ever put into
i would worry about burnout long term
long term
because this reminds me like you know
miley cyrus oh yeah look at miley cyrus
now
she hates her former self who was
basically this
she hates it so much that she's gone so
far the other way she's now taking every
drug and dick in
ellie good luck by the way i'm not you
know no judging yet yeah just because
you wish you were in l.a she's cool as
[__]
she's trying so hard to be the rock
chick now because she hates what she
wants
right and what is the worry is what are
we setting this young person up to
eventually feel the need to rebel
against
i know some of this was her idea but
clearly people are pushing it as well in
the background
yeah in order for her to develop the
business she has at such a young age
there has to be adults around her
supporting this and pushing it i'm not
that comfortable
that's all i'm saying like she's a
hard-working girl it's 17
i was like yeah i might study you know i
might get a nice i had a part-time job i
was you know
i was dusting around you've got to have
those years to find out who the [__] you
are
credit uh don't get me wrong she's
making a hell of a career for herself
and she's set for life so there's that i
hope she takes a break
yeah i hope she fight like now that
she's come out and she came out in a
really funny way to be fair
hilarious obviously my cousin got me a
new shirt right and this was her way of
coming out now
crowded do her all my overall point is i
think it's great that she's
felt at such a young age the strength
and freedom to admit
who she really is and that's a hell of a
step i hope the people
in the background are also thinking
about what she's gonna need moving
forward to grow up as an adult and not
be [__] up by this because as someone
who came into this
weird internet thing and nowhere near
the level of fame that she's got as an
adult myself
it's hard right so i can't imagine how
hard it can be when you're her age
and we've seen what happened to [__]
macaulay culkin and all these
child actors they all end up [__] up
so they need to look after this last
basically yeah because otherwise she'll
end up looking like us
or worse now brian a question that
affects both you and i
should influence us be allowed to travel
this morning ask this very serious
oh literally should influence us be
allowed to travel well no no it's a
question
oh so they're they're also yeah you
don't don't you answer it
someone from your neck of the woods she
thought she'd defend herself while she
was living out in
dubai well sheridan joins us now live
from dubai
this morning in the sunshine by a pool
something that
the rest of us are just dreaming of at
the moment
[Music]
she's not in england loving life i'm
sure it's not
in the spirit of it is it when when at
the moment in lockdown everybody is just
wanting to
you know we're in this together that's
what it feels like however
are we are we in this together when
different rules for different people
are we in this together when james and
barbara's are shot but other people are
allowed to open pub owners are getting
[__] over philip and holly are able to
make a living are we are we in this
together are we in this together
when adenance and joshua fight
mayweather can fly in the day before and
be allowed to wander around without a
mask
he's not got an exemption by the way
just just to be absolutely clear i know
someone
who couldn't let many people go to their
funeral that's quite sad
are we in this together when people are
saying goodbye to their loved ones on
facetime
yeah i feel like some of us are in it
together and then there's the
millionaires
i don't understand is my job so my job
is to motivate people this one was
probably the worst representation of uh
first of all your yard i don't know
where she's from before you put that on
me
oh you're telling me she doesn't have an
accent that came around your bits
and secondly this woman definitely isn't
a representative of influencers out
there all right
i doubt she's ever had as i'm pregnant
let's be honest a lot of influencers are
[__] off to dubai in the last few
months
yeah so i mean she is we haven't we've
got the kick off yeah
well i'll be honest if i could have done
it i would have really why the [__]
would i want to stay in england i can't
[__] do anything yet [__]
if i was going to be lazy if i was going
to sit back if i didn't i couldn't buy
that provider service thank god she's
providing the service
i know that when i'm i'm in lockdown i
think to myself god i just need to see a
woman on a camel oh i finally could see
a woman on a camel that would make it
all better
oh god i would love nothing
was essential what you posted there was
essential he does make a good point
riding a camel is not essential although
when you're in the desert it is
absolutely essential so what they're
missing out here brian is it's the way
of life out there it's a way of life
when in dubai ride a camel i mean yeah
there's loads of videos on my instagram
obviously that was just one way riding a
camel
but you know what i mean um i think if
you have a look at i said look at my
instagram you see workouts but
i think in a world where you can be
anything be kind what's that got to do
with this in a world where you can be
anything
be kind i think she got it off steve
ball it's instagram
probably she's actually wearing a little
hat shout out steve if you're watching
i just say something when you say be
kind like when we see how stretched the
nhs is and those nurses that are working
really really hard
and all they are saying is please stay
home please stay home do the right thing
stay home
and you're saying be kind are you being
kind to them
with all due respect i don't know what
the nhs nurses have got to do with
anyone out in dubai right now right
exactly what the [__] like if you're
going to criticize the girl for going to
dubai
come on holly it's an open [__]
goldman come correct
she's she's gone out to dubai there's so
many things you can have agora for
yeah a dress scene putting this strain
of the nhs on her
i'm sorry you interviewed boris johnson
and you the pair of you
got on knees and sucked the man off took
selfies with the guy this is the man who
was responsible for the state of the nhs
right now
the man who's telling us let's help the
nhs by
not being around each other meanwhile
the the same
conservative party have underfunded it
for over for decades
and you piped him off but then you're
having a go at this [__] girl
who's off in dubai about the nhs you
[__] scab
yeah she's ditzy she's stupid she's out
in dubai living life and i get
people don't like that but you had your
chance about the nhs with a man who can
actually affect it
and you [__] pipe them off so shut
the [__] up about it with her
now brian it's about to get very
technical keep up okay game
stop to shop right kind of failing at
the time
in america in america you kind of have
similar things in england i think they
sell like sort of old computer games
that sort of thing not doing
particularly well
well why would everything was online
right now these guys have obviously got
shares out there in the public so that
people could invest in them right
now there's obviously a lot of people
who want to invest in shares but some
people do this thing where they bet
against the company doing well
and that's called shorting it's quite a
simple idea big hedge funds go
we'll bet that these guys do bad and
that their price goes down
it basically makes you money through
well it's a complex trade realistically
considering it's like blockbuster but
for gaming you'd have thought it would
do bad
right so now reddit picked this up and
it's it's a very specific reddit page
called wall street
bets basically a load of random people
who aren't particularly trade savvy
should we say get together and go
on my own i've got a couple hundred
dollars but together
we have a lot of dollars so if we all do
things together
we can boot the system we can beat the
system we can make money what they were
pissed off about was the fact that hedge
funds had chosen to
short gamestop and so they wanted to do
the complete opposite and make sure
the prices for gamestop surge they did
that and some people have become
multi-millionaires on the other side of
this
because they invested i think it could
be up to 10 times
more in value than it was so this is
similar to what happened
well kind of what they used to do on
wolf of wall street they played the game
and they controlled it don't they
right from both sides yes so they
control these these stocks and shares
and they're still doing it and people
are still making money off it now it's a
fake bubble which could both burst at
any moment we don't know when it will
burst but the fact is
there are people making millions of
dollars out of this just from investing
in gamestop
which is now by the way a fortune 500
company this is weird though because
why the [__] am i going the gamestop to
buy games no why would i bother you're
not the point is
it's not actually a company that's
really worth investing in but these guys
on reddit
[__] over these people who short
positions because they thought hey these
guys the only people really [__] here
are hedge fund managers and hey let's
face it none of us like hedge fund
managers if you're trying to get in on
it now i'll tell you now
you're a little late because the prices
have gone very high you don't know when
it's gonna burst don't invest but if you
invested a couple of days ago there's
one guy on youtube invested fifty
thousand dollars he's up into the
millions of dollars that he is getting
as a return
i really need to get onto this it's
unbelievable i can't believe you're not
doing day trading you don't have the
time i get it i'm too busy learning
polka boxing doing the kick off the
knockout true news
yeah do the podcast the point is though
they trade
day traders beat the pros and that's all
that matters here people like you
like me we don't normally make a lot of
money on this sort of thing these guys
made money
they smashed it it's [__] sick it's
[__] great
right folks she existed disclaimer
disclaimer
you cannot buy this burger in the uk can
i just say has
dave left the country to get the burger
brought it back in with them because
i hope he knows he's responsible for the
nhs struggles right now yeah and i think
in many ways
we all are in a world where you can be
anything be kind
i'm doing something a little bit
different today well i'm not doing
anything different i'm a really june oh
i'm doing something a bit different well
it's not different anyway i'm just
eating food and reviewing it
um i go through the internet looking for
different new foods that will be out
in the uh country uh so i can get there
and review them what i do is i go on
there i look at places like uh
i won't give you my secrets away so what
i do with
i google it do you mind if i don't tell
you actually because
i just rather keep that to me you google
it what what we don't want
just just a thing for dave right now no
one cares where the [__] you got all of
the information we only care about you
that's the only thing we care about you
google it anyone can review food it's
the way you do it
i love let them try to copy you
no one will match you you can't out day
of a day of like dave no that's not
happening
in a world where you can be anything
dave be dave right
mcdonald's it's mcdonald's and china
they've got together and what they've
done they've done this folks right
mcdonald's in china have chosen to do a
collaboration mcdonald's went oh china
do you think we do something i do like
the fact that when they launched a
burger it says mcdonald's ex china
yeah exactly yeah um mcdonald's china
offering
offers burger featuring spam
and crushed oreos the announcement on
mcdonald's china website described the
taste of the oreo
and spam burger as tender and juicy
sounds like you june hey so we've got
oreos we've got
spam spam spam spam spam spam spam
spam lean out he's actually making the
spam and oreo
thing right i'm worried though i'll tell
you what i'm gonna do i'm gonna try and
be a little bit more ingenious
i know that's what most geniuses say i'm
gonna try and be a little bit more
ingenious it's not when you think of
genius though you don't imagine this
being the image
that you see do you well no of course
not but that's because dave's pointing a
camera at a counter with
two pieces of spam in between untoasted
bread buns
right so here we go then folks let's
tuck into the chinese
spam oreo mcdonald's burger
made here in the east midlands by the
fat lab
and juni baby i predict that's going to
be quite nice
that can't be nice i don't know
he's tasted that many things now his
taste buds have just gone he's a wreck
yeah it's all it's all it's continental
he doesn't
this has gone tremendously this is no
spam mayonnaise
an oreo in a burger and this man's going
i don't know what we're going to do next
how you a bit of corned beef in
in a [__] caramel in a [__]
sandwich like that actually does sound
amazing if anything what you've done is
you've created a better sandwich than
what dave's made well
but this is mental that was true news i
think we've given you enough for one
week
congrats it'll be back soon it's been a
while yeah
um hit the like button all of that we're
on twitch all the [__] time now check
socials it's free subscribe to us on
twitch
if you want as well you can that's just
a little donation monthly you can give
us if you
want to support the kick off the
knockout for free though even if
it's a watch for free yeah exactly you
can do as you wish but if you want to
help the show it's fine good luck
if you haven't already hit the like
button subscribe to the true jordan
youtube channel
and we'll see you later